So today on our deep dive, we are trying to decode what is basically a medieval operating system for the physical universe.
I mean, we're looking at a really huge stack of sources here.
Yeah, it is quite a lot of ground to cover.
Exactly.
We've got early Fatimid cosmology, some intense legal treatises, and really clear modern analyses from scholars like Henry Corbin, Farhad Daftry, and Khalil Andani.
We are stepping into a worldview where time and space are literal languages.
So let's just jump straight in.
Welcome.
We're with the master and the disciple the moment the scholar names the seven speaker prophets and shows outer and inner as the body and spirit of religion, each living only through the other.
We really need to lay down the absolute core thesis here immediately.
The inner is the true religion.
The outer is its revealed paths and symbols, body and spirit, each subsisting only through the other.
Yeah, I mean, that is just a massive statement to start out with.
It really is.
And to understand why that thesis is so important, we have to look at the crisis happening in the text itself.
We have the student, the seeker, who comes to his teacher, the elder.
He is in a lot of distress, actually.
Exactly.
He is having this very specific agonizing crisis of faith.
He looks around at the physical earth, the changing seasons, the sky, the oceans, all the things he believes God made beautifully.
But his religious authorities seemed totally hostile to it all.
He seemed to resent the physical world.
Yes.
And he asks the teacher, you know, why did the pious constantly condemn this lower world?
Why is spirituality always pitched as like a way of escaping the physical reality the creator built?
And that is a completely valid theological tension.
I mean, if you hold a foundational belief that creation is deliberate, then looking at the physical results of that creation with disgust is just a huge contradiction.
It doesn't make any sense.
No, it doesn't.
And when faced with that contradiction, the first answer that a lot of religious philosophers historically reached for was pure allegorism.
Meaning what exactly?
Meaning they would try to solve the tension by arguing that the physical world and all the rigorous physical rituals of religion aren't actually real or binding.
They would claim these things are simply loose metaphors for a higher detached spiritual truth.
That sounds like wordplay.
How is this different from any allegorists' trick?
Because, I mean, if you just turn everything into a vague metaphor, you can make a sacred text or the physical world mean absolutely whatever is convenient for you.
Absolutely.
It just feels like a dodge to avoid dealing with the actual dirt, the stone, and the rigid laws of the world.
Well, the scholar in the text agrees with you entirely.
He does not offer the student that cheap allegorical dodge where the physical realm is just casually dismissed.
Instead, the teacher answers the crisis by revealing a massive, objective mathematical architecture.
Okay, so he gets structural.
Very structural.
Remember, this text originates perfectly in the intellectual climate of the Fatimids.
They were an intellectual powerhouse in the 10th century.
They weren't just collecting poetic metaphors.
Their cosmology was a strict science of spiritual reality.
To prove this to the disciple, the elder introduces the foundational lineage of history, the seven speaker prophets.
So these would be the major messengers who institute the divine law throughout human history.
The text names them systematically as Adam, Noah, Abraham, Moses, Jesus, Muhammad, peace, and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family, and finally the awaited one.
Yeah, that exact list is the absolute load-bearing skeleton of this entire tradition.
the modern scholar Farhad Daftari.
He traces this specific sequence through all the major theologians of that era.
It is remarkably consistent across all their work.
It is.
And Henry Corbin pointed out a truly fascinating element of this structure.
He noted that in this framework, time itself is shaped like an alphabet.
Wait, shaped like an alphabet?
Yes.
Each of those seven heralds is a vital letter.
They aren't just
like historical figures who lived and died in the past.
They are the structural pillars holding up the spiritual universe.
So the elder is essentially handing the student a blueprint.
But if time is an alphabet, how does that actually map onto the physical sky that the student is looking up at?
This is where the mathematical symmetry becomes visible.
The text explains that those 7 messengers are the inner spiritual aspect of the seven visible heavens.
and the structure cascades downward from there into what we can observe as the 12s and 30s.
The 12s and 30s.
Walk us through that mapping.
So beneath the speaker prophets are the imams who act as spiritual sons for their specific eras.
And each of those spiritual sons has 12 highly ranked intellectual guides known as chieftains.
Oh, so those 12 chieftains perfectly mirror the 12 constellations of the zodiac in the sky above.
You've got it.
The celestial mechanics directly reflect the spiritual hierarchy, and it continues to ground itself closer to human life.
The imams have 12 proofs.
These are intellectual strongholds, and they correspond perfectly to the 12 physical regions of the earth.
And the 30s, where do they come in?
Beneath the proofs, operating locally on the ground, are 30 summoners.
and those 30 summers correspond exactly to the 30 days of the month.
That is amazing because if you pause and think about what that means for you as a listener living in this framework, it completely rewires the act of observing time.
when you watch a month roll from a new moon to the next new moon, you aren't just tracking a rock orbiting a planet.
You're watching the spiritual calendar.
Yes, it is the visible 30-day enactment of the spiritual sun's governance.
The celestial calendar is running on the exact same underlying math as the hierarchy.
I don't buy that yet calling the inner the true religion demotes the law to a costume.
Like even with all this brilliant mathematical symmetry, it makes it sound like the physical practices, the
ruling daily rituals, the mundane grind of the revealed law are just a superficial shell that you eventually discard once you figure out the celestial math underneath.
And the author perfectly anticipates that exact pitfall.
The moment you elevate the esoteric, human nature tends to abandon the exoteric.
The elder pivots to address this directly by introducing the doctrine of mutual subsistence.
Mutual subsistence.
Okay, let's unpack that.
Before we do, let me ground this by repeating the core thesis verbatim.
The inner is the true religion.
The outer is its revealed paths and symbols, body and spirit, each subsisting only through the other.
Okay, the analogy of body and spirit, that is the first major governing image the text uses.
We need to explore exactly how those two rely on one another.
It's A rigorous medical and spiritual diagnostic tool.
The scholar explains to the student that esoteric meaning, you know, the inner truth without outer physical practice is a spirit without a body.
Which would basically be a wraith.
Exactly.
It's an apparition.
If you think about a spirit.
without a physical form.
It can't walk the earth.
It can't move a stone.
It has no friction and no tangible presence in the world of action.
It's purely theoretical.
You can't actually interact with a wraith.
And conversely, exoteric practice, just doing the outer rituals and following the strict letter of the law without inner meaning is a body without a spirit.
Which makes it a corpse.
A corpse.
You might mechanically move the limbs of a corpse through the motions of a ritual.
But it doesn't live.
It has no consciousness.
Neither the wraith nor the corpse can exist as a living, functioning religion.
Practice without meaning is dead, and meaning without practice is a ghost.
They mutually subsist.
What is fascinating is that this wasn't merely A philosophical comfort for an anxious student.
This dynamic of body and spirit was the actual operating logic of their civic institutions.
It was heavily formalized.
We see this exact anatomy of faith mirrored in the strictest legal architecture of the era.
The chief judge, the Fatimid jurist who authored the foundational legal treatise, The Pillars of Islam, enforces this identical framework.
Like a court of law.
Yes.
The legal master writes that outer practice without inner meaning is like a body without a soul.
And inner meaning without outer practice is like a soul that has no body to walk the earth in.
So jurisprudence demanded the presence of both.
Absolutely.
And we find this harmonious structure again in the words of the commander of the faithful, peace be upon him.
In Peak of Eloquence, he frames this mutual subsistence from the perspective of the individual human being.
How does he put it?
He states, faith is recognition by the heart, confession by the tongue, and action by the limbs.
When you look at the sermon collection through the lens of this text, that maps perfectly.
The recognition by the heart is the inner spirit.
The action by the limbs is the outer body.
And the tongue is the seam where the two finally meet and articulate one another.
Exactly.
If you remove the inner recognition, the outer action of the limbs is just empty theater.
If you remove the outer action, the inner recognition is just a private, unmanifested fantasy.
This brings up a critical question.
regarding how they approach scripture.
If physical laws cannot be discarded, but inner meaning is paramount, what happens when they encounter A scriptural story that seems entirely unscientific?
They utilize a highly specific method of reading known in English as inner interpretation.
And the original linguistic root for this term shares its origin with the word for first.
First.
So they aren't just inventing a secret modern meaning.
No, to them, the physical world is the final solidified emanation of divine will.
To understand it, you must carry the outer form backward, up the chain of emanation, to its first originating spiritual state.
They are carrying the text back to its origin.
Yes.
And they applied this rigorously, guided by empirical observation.
The modern scholar Khalil Andani documents how the author approached the foundational story of Adam.
Well, the author looked at the biological reality of human reproduction, and he rejected the idea of a literal, physical creation of a man from a pile of mud.
He argued that such a reading contradicted empirical reality.
So he applied inner interpretation.
He did.
He argued that Adam was naturally born from a human father and mother.
The clay mentioned in the scripture is carried back to its source.
It is a profound symbol of his spiritual formation and malleability under divine instruction.
Isn't this just replacing one literalism with a literalism of symbols?
It feels like we are just trading a physical dictionary for a metaphorical one.
I mean, if you look up clay and it strictly means spiritual formation, isn't that equally rigid?
The elder anticipates that exact frustration from the student.
He answers it with a careful inversion about how we engage with the physical world, bringing the disciple back to his initial crisis.
The crisis of why the scholars condemn this beautiful lower world.
Yes.
The elder explains that scholars only forbade
world in the exact same sense that Allah forbade eating dead flesh.
Wait, let's explore that.
Eating dead flesh.
If you recall the earlier analogy, a body without a spirit is a corpse.
Oh, I see.
If you approach the physical world, the rivers, the food, the wealth, the structures,
without recognizing the divine spirit that animates it, then you are simply consuming dead flesh.
You are engaging with a corpse.
That is what is spiritually forbidden, living for the physical world alone, as if it has no syntax and no purpose.
But the moment you recognize the spirit animating the body, the body becomes lawful.
It becomes pleasing and vibrant.
The text relies on the Quranic protocol for this.
citing the chapter on what is made distinct, verse 53 in the Picolong translation.
How does that verse go?
It says, we shall show them our signs and the horizons and within themselves until it is manifest to them that it is the truth.
The horizons are the outer physical book.
The selves are the inner spiritual book.
That verse isn't just poetry.
It is an explicit command to learn how to read your environment.
And to teach the student how to actually practice this reading, the teacher provides the second major analogy, the dust mote.
Okay, the speck of dust.
He tells the student to visualize a microscopic speck of dust floating in a beam of light.
He explains that even this tiny speck is bound by 6 distinct sides, front, back, right, left, top, and bottom.
And the moat itself constitutes the 7th element.
Exactly.
It is a portable cosmology.
That is the perfect way to conceptualize it.
Yeah.
The six sides point to the six root principles of creation, with the surrounding air acting as the 7th.
The student learns that no matter how microscopic a physical object is, it contains the entire architecture of the universe.
And from that single speck of dust, the teacher gives the student a point-by-point lexicon for the massive geographic features of the earth, doesn't he?
Does.
He expands outward.
The heaven, towering above and encompassing everything, points to the overarching authority of the speaker prophet.
The 12 mansions of the zodiac and their stars point to the chieftains.
The solid earth, serving as a resting place, points to the gate and the designated trustee.
What about the specific geography of the earth, like the islands and the water?
The islands of the earth point to the proofs.
You think about the physical nature of an island.
It is an isolated, unshakable stronghold of solid ground, situated amidst A vast, shifting sea.
The proofs are those exact intellectual strongholds in the spiritual hierarchy.
Meanwhile, the rivers and springs point to the summoners, the local teachers who flow through the communities, bringing nourishment directly to the people.
Which leads to the third major analogy in the text, the critical distinction between the salt sea and the sweet spring water.
Yes.
The elder explains that the salty sea water represents outer exoteric knowledge.
It is vast, it covers the entire earth, it provides crucial boundaries, and salt preserves things from rotting.
But you cannot drink it, and it offers no support for agricultural growth.
No.
The sweet fresh water from the springs represents inner esoteric knowledge.
This maps flawlessly to the scriptural separation of the waters.
The chapter on the originator, verse 12 in the Yusuf Ali translation, states that the two seas are not alike.
This is fresh, sweet, pleasant to drink, and that is salt and bitter.
Both are water.
Both are absolutely necessary for the planet to function.
Both are forms of life.
But only the sweet water feeds the field.
If you attempt to water your crops with salt water from the ocean, you scorch the earth and the field dies.
You need the inner knowledge, the fresh water distributed by the summoners to actually cultivate a living soul and bring forth fruit.
Exactly.
I have to make an honest concession here.
I mean, when you lay out the mechanics of the water analogy like that, the entire system
It finally clicks for me.
This worldview is not about abandoning the physical world, and it certainly is not about reducing the world to a cheap, disposable costume.
It is about walking through the world, eating a meal, weathering a storm, and doing it as an active reader.
Oh, absolutely.
It refuses the exoteric literalism that worships only the surface, but it equally refuses the esoteric dismissal that ignores the surface entirely.
And that is the exact breakthrough the disciple achieves.
He learns to live within the physical world
as a reader, finding the creator's syntax in everything.
Which brings us to the altide stakes of the text.
Why does this entire chain of intermediaries, the seven heralds, the chieftains, the proofs, the summoners, actually matter?
Yeah, why is it structurally necessary?
Because without this unbroken chain, Allah's argument cannot reach his creatures.
This is where argument and justice are inextricably paired.
Precisely.
You cannot have demonstrated justice without a completed argument.
If a divine law or a spiritual truth has not effectively reached a population through a reliable mechanism, it cannot justly be held against them.
The text rests this on the chapter on the night journey, verse 15 from the Pictall translation.
And we never punish until we have sent a messenger.
So the chain of intermediaries is not just an optional, decorative hierarchy for mystics.
It is a necessary mechanism for divine justice.
It is what makes the universe morally readable.
The hierarchy is the specific channel through which the argument is delivered to creation, both outwardly through the law and inwardly through the spirit.
Without the chain, the argument remains incomplete.
Without the completed argument, justice cannot be demonstrated.
Practice and meaning rely entirely on this transmission.
They die without each other.
If we synthesize this entire journey, we started with a student standing in the beauty of the physical world, feeling totally alienated, having a crisis about why the authorities seemed to condemn it.
And the teacher answered not by telling him to destroy his attachment to the world, but by opening the world up.
He revealed the grand calendar of the seven speaker prophets, the mathematical rhythm of the 12s and 30s,
proving that the physical cosmos and the spiritual lineage are beating to the exact same drum.
The text took us from alienation to the profound realization that the entire physical universe is an open, legible book.
The heavens, the earth, the islands, the salt and fresh water, they are not random background noise, they are deliberate sentences.
They are the body animated by the spirit.
Which brings us back to the core thesis of this entire architecture.
The inner is the true religion.
The outer is its revealed paths and symbols, body and spirit, each subsisting only through the other.
When we think about reading the physical world, it is fascinating to consider how deeply this resonates with modern empirical science.
Today, we know that the cells in our bodies are governed by the literal syntax of DNA, a microscopic physical code that dictates the shape of life.
The scholars of the 10th century would have recognized that empirical reality immediately as yet another hidden alphabet animating the outer form.
So as you carry this framework forward, consider your own ordinary routine.
Think about a meal you eat, a walk around your neighborhood, a glance up at the sky, or simply pouring yourself a cup of water.
Which of those elements has been a sentence you have not been reading?
And what one habit this week would teach you to read it?